After having cancer surgery and taking supplements, I seem to have a persistent post-nasal
drip that bothers me every morning and many evenings. I never experienced this before my surgery,
change of diet, and taking supplements. I wash my nasal cavity with salt and alcohol nasal
wash, and that helps with clearing the mucus. I also take your clear histamine scavenger quite often
and also benefit from that end benadural. I was just wondered if there were other tests and protocols
I should do and any other recommendations you have regarding this. So if a person has persistent
post-nasal drip, persistent inflammation of the nasal cavity, you think of things like
chronic sinus infection or you think of polyps like I have or you think of things like
allergies. So if your help to buy a clear histamine scavenger, then you start thinking
more and benadural could help a sinus infection, the symptoms of sinus infection too. But with
clear histamine to have a scavenger helping you think more on the side of possible allergies.
So then you think, well, this is right after surgery. What would surgery do to, as a precursor,
to stimulate an allergic reaction? Well, surgery affects your body in a way that
creates a hypergrowth response to try to help your body heal post-surgery and that is going to
increase this, increase a immune hyper cytokine response in the process of healing post-surgery,
which in itself can spark an allergy to something. So you could develop sensitivities.
And what I would think of if this is, if the post-nasal drip doesn't go seasonally,
then you start thinking of a food-borne allergy. So it might have been something you were just
eating after the surgery that now that you do your entire life with no issues. And now you have a
hypersensitivity too. So you have antibodies to the peptides of that food.
That's what I would think of. So the tests that I would think of running would be the Cyrex
Array 10. To see do I have antibodies to foods that I'm eating all the time that I've ate my entire
life and now I've developed antibodies to these things and I'm developing this allergic response
because of that, that would be my first step is that we can rule out a chronic sinus infection
based upon the time, like the time, and it doesn't necessarily come and go when you're not having
other symptoms in an elevated white blood cell count, etc. So I would think that you've developed
antibodies. That's something that happens very common after surgery. And we could easily find
don't if that's true by riding a Cyrex Array 10. And you might be shocked at something that you're
sensitive to, then how can I be sensitive to that? I ate that my entire life. Well, you didn't,
because of the surgery now you developed antibodies against that. It couldn't be, let's say,
if I didn't have surgery, let's use a different example here. I'm gonna teach you a moment here.
I didn't have surgery. I changed my diet. Well, again, a change of diet, even if you're eating
better food, I never used to eat these things all the time. Now I'm eating them and they're good for me.
Let's just say, um, salad, okay, or greens or something like that. They're good for me. Why am I,
if you have antibodies too though, that thing, even a good food, you can have antibodies to something
that is really, really good for you. It doesn't make any difference if it's good for you or not good for
you. Antibodies to a food are gonna develop a inflammatory response. So it could be that you're
eating things you didn't eat before and you've developed antibodies against those things.
Thirdly, let's say you didn't have surgery and you didn't change your diet and you just started
taking supplements and now you've developed this allergic type response. Could you be allergic to
something you're taking? That's a possibility as well. I would first think that it could be
like a sensitivity to the capsules of the supplements, not so much what's in the supplements itself.
But if your, if, if certain supplements help, then that would kind of rule that out.
So I would go back to food sensitivities as my first differential diagnosis and that would be the
first thing that I would look at, um, is, is that? That's what that's the thing I would look at.
So Cyrex array 10, you could just order it on the store if you want to talk to me,
you could schedule a time with me too.